welcome to omits launching an Innovative
training program designed to embed
data-driven Concepts into biological
projects spanning the students Journey
from being a mere Observer to an active
participant in research
gone are the days when researchers had
to rely solely on manual methods and
endless lab work nowadays computers and
specialized softwares have become an
essential part of a biologist toolkit
major improvements in sequencing
technology along with reduced calls has
led to the or ID of Big Data hosting new
challenges in terms of data mining and
management
coupled with an ever increasing amount
of banknotic tools biological Big Data
continues to have profound implications
on the predictability and
reproducibility of bioinformatic results
atomics logic we recognize the
significance of these challenges and
have meticulously designed our program
to address them through our
comprehensive curriculum we not only
provide you with a solid foundation in
bioinformatics but also equip you to the
tools and techniques needed to navigate
the complexities of biological Big Data
the program offers three levels of
training beginner intermediate and
advanced each level builds upon the
previous one and covers increasingly
complex Concepts and techniques in the
beginner level you will cover key
Concepts in molecular biology and
bioinformatics and get an overview of
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and so on
you will also be introduced to the by
info server a Bionicle Matrix analysis
platform designed for biologists and
clinicians working with complex and
large data sets with such vast amount of
data generated it becomes evident that
more than regular learning skills will
be required to effectively handle and
analyze the data in the intermediate
level that is why we will help you
familiarize the genomic data analysis
skills such as multiple sequence
alignment phylogenetic analysis bear in
calling and adaptation you will also
cover Topics in metagenomenclient
analysis such as taxonomy classification
data 2 and so on Additionally you will
also become familiar with bulk RNA seek
analysis Downstream analysis biological
interpretation for transcriptomic data
analysis in the advanced level you will
be covering topics of machine learning
and learn techniques such as
unsupervised and supervised recording
exercises in RN python this level will
help students gain practical experience
in programming this level will culminate
in a Capstone project where students
conduct a literature review develop a
project proposal apply machine learning
techniques and other data analysis
skills to analyze data and present their
findings
to learn more about the introduction to
Big Data by informatics training program
we encourage you to visit the training
program website
wherein we have provided the program
overview the key features of the
training program the various skills you
will gain a comprehensive breakdown of
the session objectives and session
outcomes of the various levels including
beginner intermediate and advanced
various Associated resources that you
get access to as well as the various
price universe with that we look forward
to seeing you at the training program
I'll pave your way towards the future
filled with Limitless possibilities